tu mens
je jure que tu ne mens pas je ne vais pas
bien je vais bien je mens un peu mais je suis
un producteur et c'est ce que je fais
et j'aurai tout ton argent je
te le promets  J'ai eu 72 heures après ça
je t'ai étranglé à mort
allez je ne suis pas un idiot tu n'as pas
peint le portrait le plus précis de
notre investisseur d'
accord nous avons eu des ennuis avant de
toujours trouver une issue
c'est partout dans la rue  vous avez besoin d'argent
pourquoi ne venez-vous pas par cet ensemble
frank pierce va être là excusez-
moi mr pierce
je suis vraiment désolé de vous déranger je peux avoir
votre autographe
frank pierce était assuré pour cinq
millions de dollars reviens juste
il ne  Je ne tourne pas un cadre ou un film et il
gagne cinq millions de dollars,
comment le ressentiriez-vous et tout ce que vous aviez à
montrer, c'était un chèque d'assurance moche,
regardez, j'ai eu une arnaque, qu'entendez-vous par une
arnaque, nous la faisons ressembler à nous '  Je
vais en fait monter un film,
nous avons fortement assuré une star qui fera
ses propres cascades
Montana ouais c'est Duke Montana  qu'est-ce que
tu fais duc montana allez jeu quotidien
russe relax tu es parfait pour cette
partie particulière
je suis vraiment connecté à l'histoire ouais mais
duc c'est comme western tu sais c'est
très masculin
félicitations
bang on le tue dans une cascade il est mort
et puis nous '  re riche
nous sommes
riches  difficile de tuer quelqu'un
nous tournons cette fantastique scène de cordage
ça va être un vrai tueur si tu veux
ces gens sont prêts à mourir pour toi
c'est le meilleur choix ça marche
quel genre d'être humain es-tu bien
je suis un producteur
[  Musique]
comment se fait-il qu'un gars qui fait un film à un million de dollars
n'ait pas une meilleure voiture en laquelle
je ne crois pas
est une flamboyance ostentatoire non
toi